in this video we're going to be talking
about
exciting electrons and we can interpret
that both ways that electrons can be
exciting
and that we're going to excite them into
higher energy levels or we're going to
think about what happens
when they get unexcited when they go
back into lower energy levels
and to help us understand this i'll
start with a simple atom
hydrogen is the simplest i know and
we're going to think about the version
of
a hydrogen that we typically see the
isotope that only has one proton in its
nucleus
and it typically has one or will have
one
electron if it's a neutral hydrogen atom
and it would normally be in its ground
state if it isn't excited yet so it's
going to be in that first shell
but it can be excited to other shells it
could be excited to
the second shell or the third
shell or the fourth shell and i this is
obviously hand drawn and not hand drawn
that well
and this is really just to help us for
visualization purposes we know that
electrons don't
orbit nuclei the way planets orbit stars
they're really more they have both
particle and wave-like properties and
they're more of a probability density
function of where you might find them
and these energy levels are associated
with different probability densities
of various energies but this is what an
electron will typically look like
if we're thinking about just a neutral
hydrogen atom where the electrons in its
ground state
now let's say we're dealing with a
hydrogen atom where the electron has
already been excited a little bit so
instead of it being in the first shell
it's already in the second shell right
over here
and what we're going to do is we're
going to hit it with a
photon that excites it even more and the
photon
and we know that light has both particle
and wave-like properties when we think
of it as a particle we think of it as a
photon
but i will depict it like this so this
light has a wavelength of 486
nanometers and we know that that
photon that hits it with a wavelength of
486 nanometers has sufficient energy
to excite this electron in this case
actually from n equals two from the
second shell to the fourth shell so
it'll go
all the way over over
there so it will absorb that photon
and then after some time it can come
back down
and when it comes back down i could do
it over here so after some time
it can that electron right over here
that excited electron
it can go back from the fourth shell to
the
second shell and when it does it it will
emit
a photon of that same wavelength
so as that does that it will
it will emit a photon of 486
nanometers so just like that we already
are starting to understand
that photons of the right energy can
excite an electron
by a shell or more than one shell when
we talk about quantum mechanics it's
this notion that photons need a certain
amount of energy in order to be able to
excite
the electron to the next energy level or
the energy level after that
things in between don't work and the
same thing is true when you're emitting
the energy
the electron is not going to go from the
fourth energy level to
some place in between the fourth and the
third it can't do that
it has these quantum states it's going
to be either in the fourth or the third
or the second or the first
not at the there's no such thing as a
three and a half shell
and we can actually answer based on this
we can think about what is the
energy difference between these shells
and the energy difference between these
shells is essentially the energy of the
photon that we emit when we go from the
fourth
energy shell from the fourth shell to
the second shell to figure out the
energy of that photon
we just have to think about some useful
formulas in quantum mechanics
the first and i'm going to just look at
it right over here is that the energy is
equal to planck's constant
times the frequency so this thing that
looks like a v this is actually the
greek
letter the lowercase greek letter nu
and this is what we typically use for
frequency especially when we're talking
about
frequencies of things like light and we
also know how to go between frequency
and wavelength because we see that the
speed of light is equal to
whatever the wavelength of that light is
times the frequency of that light
so how would we figure out the energy of
one photon of 486 nanometer light
well we could think about it this way we
can first figure out its frequency
using c is equal to lambda times nu let
me write this down
so we know that c the speed of light is
equal to the wavelength
of the light times times
the frequency of that light and so if we
know
the wavelength we can figure out the
frequency
by dividing both sides by lambda so
let's do that
so if we divide both sides by lambda we
get that the
frequency of the light is going to be
equal to the speed of light
divided by the wavelength of the light
remember they've given us the wavelength
of the light here 486 nanometers at
least
i have given it to you and then you
could take this
and plug it back into planck's equation
up here that energy is equal to planck's
constant times the frequency
to figure out the energy so let me write
that down so the energy
is going to be equal to planck's
constant times the frequency
well we know the frequency right over
here so it's going to be equal to
planck's constant
times the speed of light divided by
divided by the wavelength of our light
which we know
is 486 nanometers 486
nanometers so we could say just scroll
down a little bit
that the energy is going to be equal to
planck's constant times
times the speed of light divided by
instead of writing the wavelength is 486
nanometers i can
write it as 486
times 10 to the negative ninth meters
a nanometer is just one billionth of a
meter
and then we can just get our calculator
out and we know what planck's constant
is they give it right over here we know
what the speed of light is right over
here
and we know that we have a maximum over
here they're giving us four significant
figures in each of these
and then we have three significant
figures here so our answer is going to
be in terms of three significant figures
i'm going to get planck's constant which
is
6.626
times 10 to the negative 34 joules
seconds
so let me write that down so times
10 to the negative 34th
and i'm going to multiply that times the
speed of light
so times 2.998
times 10 to the 8th
meters per second gets me this business
and then i'm going to divide that by
divide that by
486 times 10
to the negative ninth gives me i think
we deserve a little bit of a drum roll
gives me this and if we were to
look at three significant figures this
would be 4.09
times 10 to the negative 19 and planck's
constant here is given in terms of
joules
4.0
times 10 to the negative 19 joules
so what that tells us is that the
difference in these energy levels
is this many joules or the energy of
that photon
that has a wavelength of 486 nanometers
that energy is 4.09 times 10 to the
negative 19 joules